what freedom did HBO give you to create
your story to tell your story that you
wouldn't have had on a traditional
network that you wouldn't have had ten
years ago with the west wing HBO gave me
complete freedom the real difference is
that when you're on network TV the
network is in business with the
advertisers and HBO is in business with
the audience that difference is all the
difference HBO doesn't care how many
people are watching the show
really they just care how much the
people who are watching the show like
the show and that's a business model
that a writer would love but they have
to care about subscribers don't they
they only care about subscribers and the
way to get subscribers is for people to
be talking about your show people be
writing about the show for the show to
get a certain amount of critical acclaim
once you've subscribed to HBO they don't
care if you're watching the newsroom or
Game of Thrones or Boardwalk Empire
girls or anything else because they're
not trying to sell you a toaster in
between acts